step tracker, smartwatches, body data devices are directly on the skin, constant EMF exposure.
What can I do about that?
Those are hard.
You know, we are really bombarded with a lot of EMF sources than our ancestors ever had,
right?
So, we wonder why we have an increase in ADD and ADHD and emotional issues and stress issues
and anxiety issues and depression issues.
All these can be tied to EMFs, at least in part, so it doesn't mean that we don't have
other things going on, but when you add EMFs, it's just you're filling your bucket with
insults that can affect your health overall.
And you just have to start, you know, siphoning through the things that you don't need your
kids to use or yourself to use.
Do I really need an Apple watch?
No, is this really improving my life that much?
No, it's time to get rid of some of this stuff.
What's more important, you know, that you can get to track your text messages 24-7 or that
you're going to prevent positive brain cancer or something like that.
I don't mean to scare people, but you have to use wisdom in the risks that you're willing
to take, be exposed to a greater amount of EMFs.
Also, you'll find that EMFs, people are more sensitive to EMFs if you had any inflammatory
damage to your brain.
So think I mentioned this video last time, and it should be something that everybody really
should watch.
Go to the website, cutters, clinic, go to the search button, I have a blog with a video
on neuroinflammation search, neuroinflammation.
The neuroinflammation button, our blog post has a video on it, it's about a half-hour video,
go through that video, half-hour of your life, but it could save your family and your friends
life.
And the reason is, is because we can have damage to our brain, causing inflammation in our
brain, causing damage to certain cells in the brain, and worse, you developing antibodies
to different neural tissue.
And when that happens, you're going to be more sensitive to infection, you're going to
be more sensitive to EMFs, you're going to be more sensitive to molds, you're going to
be more sensitive to all sorts of things.
So if you can understand that pattern, it can be ways to call that pattern out, the better
off you're going to be.
We have all sorts of different devices that you could use to decrease EMFs.
If you go on our store, you could search EMF devices, we have a little wristband that
you could wear, and a necklace that you could wear, that could decrease EMFs.
We have grow-dead sheets that will help with EMFs.
We have static, brand devices that you could plug into your plugs at home or connect to
your electrical box that will decrease dirty electricity in your house.
There's a lot of different things that you could do to help with EMFs, but if you don't cut
out a lot of things, it's going to be difficult.
And if you don't address the inflammation in the brain that is causing such ill health
with the EMFs, it's going to be difficult.
So the more things, the more ways that you can attack this, the better you're going to
be, and the better way you're going to be able to prevent issues.
Can you send the link for the product offered?
Yeah, maybe Dustin can do that.
I don't know.
So if you go to our store, go to cuttersclinic.com, and here is a link that Dustin sent me.
Let's see if I can put it in here.
You go to our store, though, and I don't know if that's entered or not, but there's a link.
Yes, that's the smart arch link.
But if you go to that, that'll get you into the store, and then that will get you, you
know, then you can search for other EMF products.
The heat rod is the little thing that sticks out of your phone that helps change the EMFs
from dangerous EMFs to not so dangerous EMFs.
You can get a large one for your home, you can get one for your laptop, you can get a different
devices that you're using, then we have a whole bunch of wearable type of EMF products.
But then go to our cuttersclinic.com website and just search EMFs and have a lot of blog
posts that will give you some other clues that you don't have to necessarily spend money
and do some things that could help.
So about here just to sell you stuff, I'm here to give you advice that's going to be help
you with your help.
Sometimes it's just stopping doing some of the things that we're already doing, that it's
going to be your best.
That's going to be your best bet.
Here's the link to the other things, just the EMF products.